a team was disqualified from the vct
stage one after they were found to have
used a known exploit the thing is the
logic behind this being an exploit is
maybe one of the most confusing things
we've ever seen in valorem players are
confused fans are confused hell i'm
confused let's see how you fare
[Music]
all right y'all before we get into the
video i gotta remind you as always hit
like button the subscribe button and to
ring the notification bell rules where
would we be without them
without a bunch of videos on this
channel for sure last month ogb from the
malaysia and singapore vct was
disqualified from the remainder of stage
1 for using a known exploit during a
game this came after they were found to
have used unauthorized comms in game as
well i talked to valerian caster husky
who gave me more context on the ruling
once news got out people quickly found
out that it was the jet exploit on haven
c site so it went down pretty hard i
think even on the players themselves
they see it as a pretty
i think someone then felt that it was
unfair
because
in their words they said that sure we
use the exploit
we did it for two rounds but both rounds
when we use the jet exploit we actually
lost that round we didn't gain anything
from that now where have we heard this
problem arising in competition before if
you're like liz i've heard you talk
about this before yes baby you would be
correct all the way back in champions
furia got in trouble for using this
exploit back then everyone was trying to
figure out wright's logic behind it
including tens who said riot paused the
game because they said that fyria didn't
exploit by jumping on top of the c box
without updraft in my opinion that's not
an exploit since it's a skill jump that
can be done with any character so i
don't know why they paused for so long
essentially what you have to do is pick
jet and you you jump onto logs on
seaside haven uh what you want to do is
when you jump off the logs you press
crouch at the same time so you would be
crouched jumping and while you're
emitted you glide towards the box and
when you hit the edge of the box like i
would say a specific pixel when you hit
the edge then you immediately release
your crouch so you get like a crouch
boost which you know makes that lets you
get on top of the box so when the obg
ruling came out i was like okay so this
really is an official exploit in riot's
eyes so much so that it's in riot's
official materials husky found what
looks to be the official bug list for
patch 4.01 after downloading the damn
thing because it is such a large file
size i looked inside and found bugs and
glitches that i'd never heard of these
publicly available bug books are
provided by riot for competitors to see
what the band exploits are in
competition or if you're like me and
extremely nosy under haven the exploit
we're talking about is plainly laid out
for people to understand it clearly
shows and i quote haven jet jet is able
to climb on crait on sea site by using
passive drift plus crouching fixed
version 4.03 the vct website for emea
has the 3.10 bug book but it has the
exact same thing listed verbatim the
game changers website lists the 4.01
book which i made sure was the same this
is a really confusing way to say i
double checked and the exploit is listed
in the bug book at least on the emea
website because it isn't available
anywhere else riot get your links in
order because so many people do this and
at least two professional teams have
proven that using jet's passive ability
to get onto that box is an exploit it
got me thinking riot has to know that
isn't the only way to get onto that box
like 10 said right and the answer is yes
they do any agent can get onto that box
using a skill jump and it is completely
allowed you guys want to hear the most
ridiculous thing what the admin said
okay the admin said
you can do the speed jump but
you're not allowed to do it with jet's
passive ability so
if you're jet and you want to do this
jump you have to do it the way like
without the passive and then it's
allowed but if you use jet's passive in
any shape and form then you get
then it's illegal i don't know how that
makes any sense at all
yes it's literally like long a
you're just using your character's
ability to glide to get up on the job
right now husky explained how this is
achievable using other agents that
aren't jet if you're not using jet you
can jump onto the seaside box the the
first box which was lower which you
could reach from locks and then what you
essentially want to do is you turn and
face the the taller box you jump and
while you jump you want to jump towards
the edge of it which is towards the
right and mid-air
uh you want to do the crouch jump if
you're not mistaken in midair you kind
of like flick to face the edge of the
box and then you release the crouch jump
and then you make it on top of there
it's very hard to pull off husky went on
to explain that this can be achieved via
a classic old boost which is our
favorite word on this channel except we
like to put the word olaf in front of it
so riot rules that you can't get onto
that box using jet's passive ability but
make no mention about getting on there
with the normal skill jump jet's passive
makes the skill jump easier and maybe
that's why it's thinking behind it
getting on top of the box is fine but
using jet's passive makes it just too
easy it should be a skill jump it's not
a cake walk riot may also think that jet
should only be able to get on top of
that box by using an updraft like greys
with a blast pack a tp a sage wall
essentially by using utility aka active
abilities which yes i agree with that
would be a completely logical and
understandable ruling
but that's not the actual ruling on top
of the box is a legal place to be on the
map it can be reached by any agent by
using a skill jump or their abilities
except jet's passive with how things are
right now
the best approach is to use utilities to
get on top of the box right because if
we don't allow the jet jump but we
somehow allow other methods that doesn't
require expanding a utility then that
would be unfair
to
a lot of other players so it's either we
go
you know
go one way or we follow or we go the
opposite way i think there's no in
between but with how right is ruling it
right now i think utilities are the way
to go because the justification of
uh
of
categorizing the jet glide as an exploit
is because she doesn't use her updraft
so it means that she saves economy right
so 150 crests they do add up over time
and secondly it kind of
tricks the enemy team into thinking that
the jet has used one updraft when she
still has both of them available so that
might present jet with some sort of
outplay capabilities down the road to be
clear i'm not saying that teams should
be able to skate by the rules rules are
rules no matter how annoying they can be
teams should follow them if the rule
states hey don't get on top of this box
by using jet's passive ability then they
should follow that what i am trying to
say is that this specific rule is
annoying if the skill jump is an exploit
for one agent passive or no passive then
it should be a banned exploit for all
agents say to the players hey you can
get on top of that box but only by using
your utility a rendezvous a wall
whatever they could patch the map and
make it so that only abilities get you
on top of that box but it's clear that
they don't mind agents skill jumping up
there it's only jet's passive that they
have an issue with so it's unlikely that
they'll mess with that map but if they
patched jet in this case and nerfed her
passive ability so she couldn't reach
the top of that box
that would be ridiculous that would be a
massive nerf across the board all for
one box on one map in the 4.04 patch
notes it's nowhere to be found but who
knows maybe they snuck a fix in there
all in all this really doesn't make
sense to me it just kind of seems like a
gentleman's agreement between riot and
the players not to do a specific jump
using a specific ability from a specific
agent on a specific map
it's all very specific we can only
speculate about their logic behind this
because as we've seen in this video
ryder pretty tight-lipped about it all i
know is that this probably won't be the
last time we see this exploiting
competition and if it happens again and
riot still hasn't explained their
reasoning i will still have the same
questions
here's the deal danny i tried for 10
minutes
to do this skill jump
i couldn't do it it's so tricky i like
rebound stuff i was like okay if i need
a crouch at the same time like i did
everything nothing i couldn't do it and
i tried for 10 minutes and like i was
just silent on vc and discord because i
was just like getting so frustrated with
myself i was sitting there and i was
like i can't do it i can't do it and
eventually i just got a stage wall put
it up and just sat there and i was like
i'm done
[Music]
like it's so tricky